gentlemen ladies we're live we are
officially live episode number 118 with
michaela sadio right behind me here make
me appreciate you made an appearance
first time on the podcast no i think
this is the first time we're doing john
stosselin daniel de martino booth now
have you guys met each other before this
is the first time
really like three minutes ago well he
was great so far he was
he was telling a fantastic story about a
friend of his back in the days on the
trading floor that
was famous for uh reading uh novels
great novels right
the american stock exchange yes
yeah the american stock exchange anyways
great uh asset classes is what he was
doing no no no no no he said it was not
record breaking remember i said great
not the greatest patrick i was 25 years
old i was staring down at the two-story
tall solomon brothers famous trading
floor where liars poker was born
basically michael lewis's saga and i
count like seven women and like i
stopped at like a hundred men and i'm
like okay if a woman can make it here
then a woman can make it anyway that was
the moment i decided i want to go to
wall street but is it true like what you
hear about what you read about on how it
is with the ratios as well as the
treatment or you just have to be tough
to make it it was back in the day i mean
hearing that wall street's gone woke is
like excuse me because it it's an
oxymoron it's not how it works there
god is it still not like that or has it
you know what i haven't been on a
trading vlog that's not true i haven't
under trading for a reason but
there's not the same kind of grunting
going on
well oh nobody would grab your ass today
on the trading floor no but when i'm on
the floor the new york stock exchange
sometimes i do see people behind me
taking interesting photographs from
interesting angles
so yeah i'm sorry about that i just
thought that you were um i mean adam
what were you doing
a photograph was was a cat company come
in public okay i'm not going to start
with that you want to go there danielle
you want to start
just out of curiosity are you are you
part of a
dog team or uh cats which one are you
more part of whatever
cat yeah really guy that's my favorite
guy over here so you got a cat tell us
why john no i have an allergic kid i
want to have a cat i dream of having a
cat got it have you ever had a dog
yeah i had cats until i
gave life to a kid who was allergic and
we've got some sympathy some particles
in the house this morning this is going
to get you by the way you too though
you're also allergic to cats i'm
allergic to cats yeah and you are not
allergic to normal yeah i'm not in any
way i love any kind of dogs animals any
of that i mean i'm just my dad on the
other on the other side my dad can't
stand animals period i got to tell you a
story about iran with my dad
in iran we're living on this fourth
story and this cat used to come okay and
he hated cats especially because his mom
my grandma had 12 cats two dogs two
parrots two snakes and a bunch of uh uh
no no no joke my my grandma loved
animals and my dad couldn't stand them
so this cat would come
and finally he got furious why are you
coming over you're making a mess right
so one day he says you know what we're
going to do we're going to feed this cat
so me my mom and my sister were like wow
that's changed he took this martadella
meat
and he went out there
and he put hot sauce all over the
martadella okay
john doesn't know the drake story but he
puts this hot sauce all over the
martadella
and we stand outside we're like wow
that's actually giving him he says no i
put hot sauce on that thing they'll
never come back the cats eat the
martadella they choked all the way down
from the fort we never saw cats ever
again that's why that's her dad's
listening to this cracking up cause he
remembers when he did this clearly
anyways
look at that we got a lot
the logo i like it they finally put it
up it's sick robert the team john
everybody phenomenal job with that logo
we love it in the vault yes in the vault
in the bank vault john just so you know
this is a bank vault that we turn into
podcasts at cool except behind all this
there's about 17 million dollars okay
and half of them are empty by the end
you're gonna be able to open it up
whichever one has money in it it's yours
when you leave okay you can only get one
choice this is like a game show it is a
game show welcome to the game show with
patrick and adam anyways topics dubai
emirates suspense flights due to 5g
concerns and it's all over the place is
it real is it just something they're
talking about elon musk laments the
declining birth rate if there aren't
enough people for earth then there
definitely won't be enough for mars big
concern for people who want to move to
mars one day
mr beast reportedly made 54 million in
2021 most ever on youtube you're a
youtuber you're a youtuber there's
youtubers here that's 54 million that's
a lot of money maybe we can talk about
uh mr beast biden's press conference who
they claim it was the greatest press
conference of all time i mean historic
the way he handled himself but this
article is a spelling error it says it
was an utter disaster so i think that
title maybe needs to be yeah it's a typo
california wants to double its taxes and
i want to know what mr stossel has to
say about that and then we've got a
bunch of other things that's going on
one story specifically adam's favorite
story that we have here uh is most of us
prioritize our pets
physical and mental health over our own
a study shows that seven out of ten pet
owners
have more concern about getting their
pets acupuncture over them it's a very
interesting study we'll get into that on
how that works out and esta so john
you've said some stuff about parents
should care about crt
andrew yang's new forward party and a
few other things here about the fda
maybe we'll get into that as well but
how about we start off with uh
california wants to double its taxes you
okay with that let's talk california
wants to double its taxes
and uh here we have two that live in
florida you right now live in new york
so i double my taxes from you how
awesome is that though but you like to
play volleyball in del rey
which is it i'd move here if my wife
didn't hate florida that's right she we
discussed this last time
okay so let's see what's going on with
california all right here we go this is
an article from national review you can
also find this article i believe on
washington examiner and tax
foundation.org but this one is national
review folks if you're living in
california or thinking about moving to
california i don't know a lot of people
are thinking about moving to california
but you might want to listen to this
california wants to double its taxes
jared walczak of the tax foundation
wrote a block post yesterday with news
that doesn't seem possible california
california an already high tax rate
wants to double its tax revenue no
matter how he broke it down the proposed
constitutional amendment the numbers are
astounding it would increase the top
marginal tax rate to 18 and a half
percent that's 7.05
higher than hawaii the next highest
state that 12 and 12.75 percent higher
than a national medium it would increase
taxes by an average of 12 250 per
household all told the new tax package
is intended to raise an additional 163
billion a year which is more than
california raising total tax revenue any
year prior to the pandemic it's not just
income taxes though the state wants to
implement a payroll tax as well with the
top tax rate applying to taxpayers
making only 49 990 an annual income
currently only massachusetts and nevada
have a payroll tax that do more than any
fund unemployment insurance it continues
the most insane part about the proposal
however is the 2.3 percent
gross receipt tax only seven states levy
gross receipt taxes which are especially
harmful to economic growth because they
are based on business revenue not
profits even if businesses lose money
they still pay the gross receipt taxes
because they still made revenue which is
insane if you ask me if this proposal
adopted california would essentially
have 18 tax brackets and individuals
making less than thousand dollars per
year wind up paying double digit
marginal tax rates thoughts mr stassel
i think it's great because we need we
got 50 states it was a wonderful design
so we could experiment and we need
models of failure
so you need models of failure
chirology so you're saying this is a
model of failure or potential failure
well i hope it will be but it is amazing
how californians can say i believe i
believe government will solve all the
problems and
we'll get the homeless off the street
and we'll
make everything nice and if i'm paying
that's okay
i made a lot of money on silicon valley
i can afford it and i'm it's a public
service
now here's a question danielle i want to
ask both of you guys curious to know
what you say i think the question is the
following newsom
when he won the recall he was going
against larry elder and if we remember
that it was convincing victory 64. it
came out of 67 by the time they got
everything it was around 63
62 but it was not even close right
so 60
plus support newsome how likely is it
that something like this could pass okay
wait wait wait wait timeout
there was a fourth stimulus check mailed
to californians right before the recall
vote so they're literally getting
1500 of cash in their bank accounts
right before they go to the polls how
convenient is that and b to john's point
about a failed experiment it failed last
year anybody guess when california was
was entered into the union year 1850
since 1850 the population of california
net net has grown every single year
until 2021 and 2021 was the first time
that they had a net decline in their
population so if they want to continue
on this merry path then they can fail
even bigger yay
and lose even more companies well here's
a question danielle for you
if 60
supported newsome what's the likelihood
that this insane tax proposal will pass
i mean if if it's only the crazy voters
coming out and the other people who are
like screw that or like leaving and they
were on the fence before they were like
if anything else crazy and i've actually
spoken to people out there who have
great companies they make good amounts
of money and they were like well we
thought the taxes were going to go up
we've already bought places elsewhere in
the country and then all the craziness
stopped but they're like if the taxes go
up i'm out of here i've already got my
plan b i actually already owned the
the property outside of the state of
california so a small exodus is going to
become a mass exodus
and do we really know that they
supported newsome because
the press portrayed larry elder is a
crazy man and larry
talks so fast and
puts out so many ideas in one quick
sentence
he turned off a lot of people i love him
and he's right on all the issues really
so you were a fan of larry elder totally
wow except for his presentation
and i think he scared people fast
talking salesman type of thing is that
okay california's like new york is a
state right if you're conservative
you're ambivalent on voting day you're
like my vote's not going to count so you
didn't even bother you're like if i
i i registered to vote against hillary
when i lived in new york you know what i
got jury duty
i mean that was it my vote didn't count
it was
it was just nonsensical my my friends
were like why are you doing this why are
you giving your texas driver's license
i've been here for seven years fine and
i'm you know she's not even from new
york i'm going to go out and vote
against her to do my duty my civic duty
and all i got was jury duty but
there's a there's a level of ambivalence
whether you're living in new york or
illinois or california and you're like
my vote if i'm a conservative my vote
doesn't counsel why bother
yeah but but here's here's the here's
the part though number one like
you know the whole theory about the you
put a frog in the water you boil it one
degree slowly and then eventually at 212
he doesn't know it's getting hotter so
he dies like you've heard the story i'm
not the first person telling you the
story right all the time yeah it's not
true yeah and it's not true no the frog
jumps out as it slowly warms you know
what we're gonna do we're gonna do this
on the podcast as an experiment next
time you're good next time just make i'm
being serious david tyler make a note
next time stossel is out here we're
going to bring a frog we're going to put
it in the water we're going to boil it
at 212 frog in a hot plate and we're
doing pod couple so you see the frog
jump out on john it would be hilarious
so that's the next experiment make a
note of it but anyways going back to
this
at what point
at what point are people gonna say
you know there is no freaking way this
makes any sense or is it already
happening elon musk originally moved
personally to texas
and now he's relocated the headquarters
yeah but remember top marginal tax rate
so what is top marginal tax rate because
a person making forty two thousand
dollars are like dude please raise the
top marginal tax rate i don't mind if
you raise a top marginal tax rate so
there's more people making less than 49
than those that are making top marginal
tax rate so a lot of the people at the
bottom they're like silicon valley ain't
going nowhere they're going to stay here
forever right like this whole thing
about what happened in detroit that'll
never happen to silicon valley new york
is a financial capital you know
hollywood is hollywood even though
atlanta and austin's kind of competing
silicon valley silicon valley miami's
becoming the crypto capital there's no
way these billionaires will leave
japanese morgan chase has more more
employees in the state of texas than jp
morgan chase has in new york
um
pat you used the analogy one time and i
think you were getting to it with the
frog is you got upset how much are you
willing to get pushed meaning like if i
do this to you yeah all right it's a
little annoying if i just if i do that a
little bit more and if i keep pushing
yeah and pushing at what point you're
like dude if you push me again i'm gonna
knock you out and that's essentially
what's happening here is like all right
we'll raise it a percentage no it's good
yeah but you know what it is here's
here's the perspective here this is what
i'm trying to ask the brains to my left
because i'm a guy with a 1.0 gpa from
high school these guys got degrees on
top of degrees and they're educated in
the world journalists legendary
journalists and federal reserve finance
here's a question
i'm doing it to you right you're getting
irritated but
if those that are making 40 grand you're
watching me do this to the billionaire
guess what they're saying do it again do
it again do it again all right it's
awesome do it again so it's yeah no no
they're excited that i'm pushing yours
they're celebrating it and newsom is
like oh you like it oh you like it yeah
oh wow okay awesome let me do some more
i think that's the dynamic right and and
by the way you know who ends up paying
the biggest price for this not for you
because who wants you
who wants you
49 other states
of course yes 49 other states want you
this
i love your analogy pat but why should
the person making 40 grand who's
watching and to get pushed watching the
billionaires get pushed watching the
millionaires get pushed
why should they care why should they
john
because life won't be as good if you
push the
producers out but why do you think that
the silicon valley won't go down like
detroit if the economics don't make
sense and people are moving to austin
and
florida
nicer places california has
mountains and an ocean and great weather
a lot going for it and bizarrely a
surplus
because the stock market went up so much
and these billionaires are paying more
in taxes
but it could bust
at what point
i don't know what point last time i
checked the nasdaq's in correction
no no i get that but i'm trying like if
you have you studied the history of
detroit on what caused it to break down
when
a mayor you know started playing games
with dearborn and they started raising
local taxes and regulation and they the
union got involved and started making
life public unions so eventually they're
like we're out of here and the next
thing you know the population went from
one and a half million to eight hundred
thousand and all those jobs left to
different places do you really think if
that happens to silicon valley it could
happen and number two is what causes
that i'm going to push one of john's
buttons yeah here we go and in texas
which is like california central because
the influx is insane and it's non-stop
a lot of parents have actually started
to leave talking about strong unions
because the la
teachers union
mandated that when they shut the schools
down that they also had to have the
private schools close as well
and the private schools was like wait a
minute we've got the protocol we can
stay open
and eventually the parents just threw in
the towel and they're like we could
afford to have stayed in california
they weren't bending on critical race
theory so a taxes b i want my children
to have an education that i want for
them to have that not that's mandated
and dictated so i'm getting the hell out
of here so california is hurting itself
in more ways than just economically
incentivizing people to leave is all i'm
saying because when your union is that
strong like it was in detroit and you
have you a public union gets the power
to close private schools
i mean come on that's not it's there's
nothing american about that
people put up with a lot
most people don't really pay attention
to the stuff we talk about
they
think about sex and music and movies and
sports and raising their families
there's the expression that ninety
percent of the people
one percent of the people make things
happen and ten percent watch and the
other ninety percent wake up and say
what happened
and people don't notice that their taxes
go up a little bit a little bit a little
bit they just take it yeah but i mean
patrick if you i mean if you're reading
correctly they're talking about doubling
yeah but but but john if you're yeah if
you double so so let's do the math let's
just say i'm paying
5 000 in taxes and i'm making 50 a year
that goes to 10 000 in taxes my car
payment is 320.
i'm gonna feel that like i remember when
i'm making 40 grand a year
what a hundred dollars was i looked at a
hundred dollars raised in a month i'm
like dude my phone goes covered next
time that's fantastic so i felt a
hundred dollars at that level but you're
contradicting yourself i know i am i
know i am i'm trying to challenge to see
at what point do people leave that's
what i'm trying to find at at what point
the silicon valley
just become a city a val you know and
all these guys are gone what will cause
them to leave
i don't know yeah i think it's the same
thing that happens in a relationship
it's that we've all i'm sure we've been
in like relationships that haven't
worked out and you get in a fight it's
like all right cool whatever it's a
fight and then you get another fight or
whatever and you're getting a fight
you're arguing and it's fighting and
then at what point you're thinking i
don't know if i want to be with this
person i don't know i don't know it just
kind of keeps happening and finally boom
something happens and you're like all
right that's it i'm i'm getting the so
it's not a one and done thing we got in
a fight we're done it's the cumulative
effect you meet someone else
you see a nicer sexier state out there
something like florida comes and winks
at you to your point
i mean at some point you're going to get
so frustrated that you're waiting
forever to get into a restaurant
because the support staff is simply not
going to be there anymore because you've
expanded the social safety net to such
an extent right the only fourth stimulus
check in america was in california
otherwise the rest of the nation just
got three and that was way too many
but that was a state federal it was a
state a state okay it was a state but at
some point you're going to get so
frustrated if you're a zillionaire that
that you don't have
the service that you want you can't go
to napa valley
and go to your favorite restaurants and
go to your favorite resorts because
there there aren't enough workers
because the social safety net is big
enough to capture them where they don't
have to work
it's at some point things start to fall
apart that's just like new york right
now i mean you wait a lot longer
at a restaurant for service and either
you want to be there you don't
you know you know what this makes me
think about it this makes me think about
in a following way how many people can
handle domestic violence
how many how many marriages do you know
where people are like you know what [ __ ]
this sucks but i'm not going anywhere
how many people stay in a marriage with
domestic that was kind of my point with
the relationships
that's adam's point but you also have
women's shelters that that are
constantly full so clearly human beings
hit their break points or the women's
shelters wouldn't be full so what i'm
saying is i think california is a form
of domestic violence to its citizens
i think california is the best example
of domestic violence and unfortunately
some are going to take it and tolerate
it and some are going to say i'm getting
the hell out of here unfortunately uh
the the logic behind the politician
what's the politician thinking about
what is the policy maker thinking about
what is a policy maker thinking long
term like what's this 163 billion going
to do like you're going to treat me
we're going to help people we have
problems here and if we have this money
we can get more social workers to help
than the neglected kids and
they believe it
clean up the homelessness everything
that's going on in san francisco i mean
we've covered uh that to uh
i mean at least de blasio left before he
was able to set up the the shooting up
heroin tents the safe spots
i mean this is already gone there this
is a question for you go forward and so
i think this is ultimately where we're
going with this is that
physically
john touched on this with the mountains
and the oceans physically california is
the most beautiful state
but
tax wise and politically it is
potentially the ugliest state you see
what i'm saying there would you agree
with that sure
so so you're like you moved out of
california for seven years but it's for
you it's kind of like you're dating
somebody who's dropped it gorgeous who
is ridiculously demanding
and nothing ever makes her or him happy
yeah how long are you going to stay in
that role that's my point is that you
can brag about it
but she's horrible to my friends and
she's horrible to my family and i can't
like and honestly she's probably also
horrible in bed you know
with uh our friend uh keith
and he had some depressing words he says
guys
we're 40. and adam is 40 about to be 41
on february 4th right is it february 4th
so he said we only have 25 good years
left in us i'm like i'm like guys we're
at dinner having drinks you know
he's like what are you talking about
yeah i feel like i got a lot of so what
do you think what are your thoughts
about that i i
don't believe it i'm over 65 and you're
playing volleyball in delray i hope to
have good years left i love that
response of john stossel i love you guys
you might as well just cart the coffins
into the vault here seriously so okay so
now let's go to a different topic so
john style so you did a story on crt
parents should care about crt right
let's go to page five
with uh john sol crt uh parents should
care about crt this is a tribe live
story glenn younkin recently was elected
virginia is governor partly because he
promised to ban featuring of crtcrt
stands for critical race theory which
argues that every american institution
upholds white supremacy journalists
asura nuamani
uh reveals some rather creepy crt
lessons that are taught in schools the
money filed freedom of information act
request that for schools district to
reveal how they pay consultants to
spread crt we found 300 plus contracts
they know me
every day i'm getting a new contract
some conservatives want to ban the
teaching of crt that's not a good idea
government shouldn't be banning ideas of
taking choices away from teachers bans
shield students from important topics a
better solution is legalizing school
choice
let parents take our tax money to a
school we choose can you unpack that
well start with the end
being if there's a market everything is
made better by competition
and you look at new york where i'm from
and you used to work they spend more
than twenty thousand dollars per kid
if you do the math that's four hundred
thousand dollars per classroom okay
how many good teachers could you hire
for that
you gotta be able to hire
four good teachers and this was not
capital cost this was just
what they put in to teach the kids every
year
so where does the money go
nobody can find out it goes it's not
just the union it's the the
administration all that the bureaucracy
and the ptas get caught up the people
who like going into windowless
conference rooms and trying to figure
out how to run other people's lives
unless there's competition that forces
them to make some cut somewhere and just
spend more on the right things that the
parents want
it'll
never get better
i don't think the critical race theory
stuff is a giant threat but
they have books like woke baby i mean
critical
theory is a law school theory
but it got down to the teachers and many
of them believe racism is everywhere
which i think is nonsense there's more
inner marriage than ever before and
isn't that a measure of racist getting
along if you
are eager to marry someone of a
different race
but some kids are being taught that
they're if you're white you're a
horrible person and you stole from
non-white people you did it well your
parents did it and passed it down to you
but you have this huge advantage
and that's evil do you do you believe uh
in the power of affirmations
i'm not sure what it means
power of affirmations like saying hey
yeah uh you know
i'm gonna have a good day today you know
be careful what you joke about but be
sarcastic about because the spirit stops
having faith and the words that comes
out of your mouth i'm meant to do
something special with my life you know
do you believe in affirmations do you
believe in affirmations daniel i do do
you believe in power of positive
thinking sure can we say we all agree
that normally i say an affirmation every
morning okay i know you do right norman
vincent peale the power of positive
thinking new york preach you know pastor
all this stuff right so i'm i'm giving a
talk and
i'm speaking in front of a group of kids
and parents probably a thousand people
in norman i'm up there talking about how
great this country is right
america is the greatest country in the
world like you know american
exceptionalism this is
the greatest place and next thing you
know i see a couple of the teachers go
like this
and i'm like okay my job is to read body
language this is what you do when you're
speaking from stage i'm like okay
curious i want to really talk to these
guys afterwards so i don't even need to
go to them they come up to me
uh listen uh first of all thank you for
coming up but can i give you some
feedback yes you have to be very careful
telling young kids a lie like america's
the greatest country in the world do you
realize america is one of the most
racist
countries in the world and she went off
right all these things about how
horrible america is
i said let me ask you a question she
said yes i said do you believe in
affirmations you said
what's after me and i told her i said do
you think it serves kids
to think positive thoughts about
themselves about their families about
their heritage about their country
i think that's a formal manipulation oh
really that's a formal manipulation
interesting so i shouldn't tell my kids
son
you can do almost everything you put
your mind to accept some things that
have physical abilities if you can't
jump 46 inches you're probably not going
to be lebron james outside of some of
physical stuff you can probably do
anything you want to do right is that a
bad thing to tell a kid
no
no but that's not the point we have to
tell people the truth about the fact
that racism exists i'm like ma'am
i just came and spoke at a white school
and i'm from iran
like do you realize how you invited me
and i spoke and i said how great your
country is this is an example of how
great america is well no you haven't
seen all the other stuff i haven't seen
all the other stuff i was in the
military went to kentucky have you lived
in south carolina or kentucky i lived in
south carolina and i went to a waffle
house which i don't miss going to waffle
house right so i go to waffle house this
guy's looking at me
saying uh where are you from
i said what do you mean
he said can i just be honest i said yeah
sure he said i've never seen a notes
like that in my life before i said this
is a legendary armenian nose you cannot
make these types of things you have to
have genetics the guy actually said that
to your face i said you realize your
pretty boy knows that you got it cost me
nine thousand dollars to make it look
like yours i said you need billions to
make yours look like money okay all the
money in the world is not gonna say he
starts laughing we start la i'm from
iran he said you're from iran i ran i
said yeah i'm from iran he said what are
you doing here
you know and we're at this waffle house
i said can i whisper too so it's not i
don't want people to know about it
because i'm in the uniform i said listen
just between us i'm a spy here i'm
trying to spy and study all your
military tactics cause i'm gonna take it
back to iran is that's why i'm here
seriously no man i'm kidding with you
he's running for his gun
so so to me the biggest thing that crt
doesn't get is affirmations work and if
you want to put negative affirmations
they also work if you tell
hundreds of thousands of kids they're
racist by the time they're 18 they're
convinced they're racist and it
continues for decades and decades and
they consume and i think that's a
problem i think it's a different
approach we can take i may be wrong
there's people fighting their way into
this country give me a break
yeah people want to come here but when
the kids are older
it's right to teach them about some of
the horrible things that america has
done
and
it was
just not taught to any kid when i was in
eighth grade
i mean i think we all went
to school and we learned about the civil
war and slavery i don't think it i don't
it wasn't called critical race theory
but we were all very well aware that
that was like a word of the that was
part of exactly when the white people
civilized america and
rescued
people from the savages that stuff was
in
my courses mm-hmm what was that
i'm vastly older than you guys but what
wrong
is that incorrect no
america
did some racist
nasty no no but your statement is that
white people civilized
he's asking is that wrong because
lincoln i think lincoln's not black
right is he white or black at last i
checked he's still awake he was a white
guy
he's not with us anymore by the way adam
the enlightenment
western values civilize the world
correct
and you're not allowed to say that
anymore but it's just true i i don't
know uh maybe glendale high school
focused on it but i remember i grew up
i grew up now i'm not going to lie to
you when i was in high school i didn't
like white people when i was in high
school because what was sold to me was
white people take advantage of everybody
else that's what was sold to me when i
my teacher was white when she's teaching
history
what they did to blacks what they did to
ray
you know till today you're not gonna
find an office of mine or anything of
mine without an mlk picture on the wall
until today mlk is a hero too too and
obviously he just had a celebration so i
don't know if the history's
unless if it's inaccurate and lincoln
didn't play a big role then we have to
talk about it
i mean i grew up learning that you know
the horrors that we inflicted upon
native native americans yeah when we
landed here i mean
took all that i mean they've got like
1.2 percent of their land left but i
mean these are
these are things that i learned growing
up in school
but i think we're missing a major point
here when you say we did this we did
this we're all immigrants my family came
over from russia in the early 1900s okay
his family came from iran i don't know
you're jewish uh you know your family
probably landed on ellis island your
19 i family
know i mean unless you're like original
og jamestown waspi english from 1600's
we all immigrated from some countries
where we had to get the hell out of
because we were getting persecuted
whether that was religiously or or
economically economically and we had to
make a move so when we we white people
how many people are just straight white
people that just landed on plymouth rock
you know like the old uh malcolm x i
didn't land on plymouth rocklin but the
rock landed on me
so the the old white people thing i just
think is it just a blanket statement
that just actually doesn't hold water to
most people am i wrong on that john
stossel no
and also
slavery was ended by white people most
college students now think
america created slavery started it now
you're contradicting yourself john
i like to do that
you do so why are you teasing me
keeping pbd on history keep going keep
going
it was the british
more than we but even people from mexico
who ended slavery but it began in the
middle east
it was perpetuated all over africa
and somehow white people are the bad
guys and it continues to this day in
various parts
six countries let's not forget that we
killed gaddafi and now there's a giant
slave trade in libya let's not forget
about that
that's your point with that it's still
at his point slave trading is still on
today there are thousands of slaves
being traded in libya
after we
bombed and assassinated gaddafi
so we shouldn't have killed
are you advocating for us not to have
killed gaddafi the voice of god called
david
you may have a good point i don't think
we should have killed gaddafi tell us
why because we brought the country into
chaos gaddafi had backed off he under he
understood that we had his number he had
backed off he wasn't
the terrorist he was
10 years ago before we assassinated and
and look what happened after he was gone
the country has fallen
into complete chaos and it's often
justified by this idea of american
exceptionalism
we go into all these other countries and
tell them how to run things and we make
it worse i mean an even worse example
than qadhafi is what's happened in iraq
we we prop up these qadhafi's these
hussein saddam husseins as these
boogeymen we these are horrible people
we got to get them out and next thing
you know that it creates this vacuum
boom isis boom slave trades in libya so
it's like what are we trading one you
know
what is he just the complete uh leader
uh totalitarian is the word i'm looking
for for basically a complete psychopath
mindset that isil brings
these are three different issues by the
way that we just we just combined
together and tyler
completely threw a little bomb in there
and then
confused everybody yeah no but but uh to
to to the point of what he's talking
with libya do you are you should should
we be involved should we not be involved
i would say you know that whole stat we
did with how many military bases we have
versus china around the world you know
how many military bases u.s has around
the world versus how many china has do
you know what i guess i don't want you
to say because you know do you know what
the number is 90 how many u.s has
worldwide
how many do you think u.s has thousands
okay
u.s has 800 military bases worldwide
china has won and it's by the what do
you call it
baby the djibouti by uh
what what do they call that suez canal
but there's a
the
how oil you know that whole uh section
is what they have they have one military
base u.s has 800.
we have thirty thousand the horn of the
the northern part of yeah yeah yeah
that's right that's right that's right
yes yeah not the suez canal 30
30 000 soldiers in korea 30 000 soldiers
cam casey is one of them yeah japan
thousand in germany
didn't we win those wars why are we
still there south korea is rich it could
defend itself from norway we might find
out this weekend why there are some in
europe
but they don't how does that talk about
play out
we've mobilized a ton of of the navy
there but i don't think anything happens
there's massive amounts of the navy
headed straight there
and we're gonna go to war over ukraine
doesn't sound like it
somebody was not well either somebody
wasn't briefed or somebody gaffed at the
podium so john
what should we be involved in what
should we not be involved in should we
be involved in anything
direct threats to the united states how
about direct threats to allies of the
united states well we have to because we
signed the nate the nato treaty so then
but these treaties which sound wonderful
we're going to have a safer world it
means
we're obligated to go to war for people
we
may no longer like
how do you mean by no longer like maybe
you sign the treaty when one
government's in power and it totally
changes but once government does
something it never undoes it back to
your original question about direct
threats or your point about direct
threats of the united states
wholeheartedly agree look what happened
in 911 that was a direct threat next
thing you know we'd have end up in
afghanistan for 20 years longest war
we've ever been in and that's been a
disaster when they pulled out a little
premature
but at what point is that direct threat
just continue and continue and continue
and continue to the point where it just
makes no sense to be there
well part of the threat continues
because they hate having our
troops
walking down their street how would you
feel if some chinese soldier in uniform
is patrolling your neighborhood would
hate it of course but we want to kill
him but wait a minute that's not always
true it's not always true i'm sorry i
disagree that's not always true because
there are many countries who feel safer
with seeing our troops walking around
then their own troops walking around
because there is that abuse tyler had
had we maintained a presence in libya do
you think that this would have degraded
to the extent that it has
no i don't think it would have but but
you know
to the point
i think when you're the largest
superpower in the world the number one
superpower in the world it is your job
to play police officer to keep people in
check and to keep a sort of world order
i mean and let's not forget that's what
these military people sign up for is to
to maintain peace and essentially save
the world i mean that's what they sign
up for
i i i agree with you and i agree with
john this is the part this we're going
to call today's shows the the the the
contradictions
are
at what point does a non-direct threat
become a direct threat so russia moves
into ukraine all right it's not a direct
threat well what if they keep moving and
advancing and eventually move into all
of europe didn't then does it become a
direct threat at what point do these
threats switch to where it's on our
radar yeah i mean
back in 1938 they were like 1939 they're
like okay all right jeremy you you can
have czechoslovakia but you better stop
there
no poland for you and britain had to go
it alone but they gave him they were
like okay we'll let you absorb one
little country
but when you give a little inch you know
you never know how these things are
going to progress and there's something
to be said for china
watching very closely i sent you an
article last night
there's something to be said for
watching very closely to whether or not
if putin does something is this going to
be seen as an opportunity for xi jinping
to do something with taiwan
and to have a coordinated effort
look putin and xi jinping don't like
each other they're they're not they're
not like hanging out on the weekends
you don't think that they're they're not
buddy buddies no they're two egomaniacs
but that being said
you know if you're talking about kicking
a country when it's down or taking
advantage of a point of vulnerability
then why wouldn't you do it at the same
time
would you say that putin and
and she or even china and russia are
more closer to allies or foes
i would say that their interests are
aligned right
they're you're saying who china and
russia china and russia they're supposed
to they have to get along economic
economically they're kind of like u.s
and mexico u.s and canada let me ask you
who do you think they hate more do you
think russia hates america more or china
more
oh america okay so china you think china
hates russia or america okay so that's
right that part the enemy of miami and
most people on mainland china believe
exactly what they've been told their
entire lives and that's that taiwan is
legally
part of china so so let's let's finish
this folks let's go let's go through all
this stuff the the
sea of contradictions that we had number
one crt
john says let him teach it because it's
a form of capitalism if some schools do
too much of it parents are going to take
their kids to a different school that's
crt now the challenge with that is if my
kids are going to public school and i
can't afford it i can't afford to take
my kids to another public school because
there's a zip code and all these other
things you're dealing with i'm a little
screwed there john if i can't afford to
take my kids to private school
no it could be public school choice
think if you were assigned to your
supermarket by your zip code
it would be
the supermarket would have no interest
in pleasing its customers
but there's a there are there are
opportunities i think to revamp the
public school system no but are you okay
if they say every public school in
america is going to come and impose a
crt philosophies on the young kids
then what do you do you and i can take
our kids to private school
but the average person making 52 is
going to say dude i can't go to delaware
still crt i can't go to new york it's
still crt i can't go anywhere i don't
think you would ever see something like
that nation might i think that the
virginia gubernatorial
election taught us that and if the
parent was if if the money were attached
to the back of the kid
and you had a system where oh that
school gets the 20 000 if i can lure
that those parents this would never
happen yeah
i
regarding crt
i don't think anything should be
banned right nothing should be banned
however i do think they're like for
instance i wouldn't want my
elementary school kid learning about crt
i wouldn't probably even want a middle
school kid but at some point 11th 12th
grade i think it's open it up let's
let's have open conversations you're
about to get ready for the real world
there's going to be a lot tougher things
you're going to deal with than a co than
a crt class or uh
as long as you're teaching both sides of
every story true but if you don't want
the government to just ban things you're
big fans of desantis and
i am in many ways
but what about his
saying it's kind of like no one may
teach critical race theory
no one may say in this school we demand
you wear a mask
that seems
totalitarian
to also not allow kids to wear masks at
certain schools
yeah not
yeah if that school chooses it and let
them do it well since
since the supreme court ruled look how
many
since the supreme court court ruled look
how many companies have abandoned their
mass mandate
yeah so by the way look while while
you're saying this let's transition into
what boris johnson just said yesterday
if you want to pull up that video we
covered a lot of different topics here
uh uh we we found out abraham lincoln is
white which is breaking extremely
important if you want to if you want to
make that bigger uh this is uh boris
johnson he just said this
three days ago go ahead
mandate the wearing rewind a little bit
the government will no longer mandate
the wearing of face masks anywhere
[Applause]
mr speaker
wait
awesome
[Music]
from tomorrow we will no longer require
face mastering classrooms
and the department for education will
shortly remove national guidance on
their use in communal areas
in the country at large we will continue
to suggest the use of face coverings in
enclosed or crowded spaces particularly
when you come into contact with people
you don't normally meet but
we will trust the judgment of the
british people
and no longer criminalize anyone who
chooses not to wear one the government
will notice he just saved his heinie
what do you think about that john
i think
british people just sound smarter
because of their accent but
yeah let
trust people if you compare the states
and i my last
video videos about that how
there's just no pattern
states that don't require mass like
florida they get smeared oh more deaths
in florida than any other place and the
slimy media does this by
mentioning florida
when you have a bad month and ignoring
florida when the numbers are good
florida is number 19 in deaths and
florida has more old people so florida's
doing pretty well despite having totally
different rules
and you
there's just no there it's the third
largest population in the country
new york uh new jersey did really badly
and they have tough rules so can you say
well locking people up makes
increased the problems from kovid no
because there were fewer deaths in
california and they had horrible rules
so there's no pattern
and everybody acts like oh yes if you
only do this
you
will solve it but we're never going to
solve
covit
it lives on in animals are we going to
require
lions and tigers to wear masks
we have to deal with this
it's a bad look lines look good they
need their mouth
what would you say danielle
i think i think that we're learning that
that common sense as prime minister
johnson said that common sense should
prevail i mean if you're like in a
really crowded
subway car
in new york
and you don't have a mask on then you
you know in the event that you've got
me mine or lupus and i get covered and
it takes my ass down
hi i was in a crowded subway car with
people breathing all over me
if i'm walking down the street or if i'm
in a store by myself yeah and it's not
crowded and i don't have my
fine housing is it going to come come up
and jump and
get me from some place across the street
no
where i live they're wearing masks and
outside i know i'm i'm in new york on
tuesday that's the freakiest thing about
new york is that there's such a fear
factor
i was in los angeles recently and there
are people walking on the streets empty
streets of los angeles downtown los
angeles and masks and i'm like
what do you think is going to get you
you're outdoors i mean that's why that's
what i'm saying government shouldn't
brainwash people out of having any
common sense
and that's what we've seen in america
and elsewhere austria just mandated
austria did vaccinations but fear is
such a powerful
motivator
and as a consumer reporter
i was eagerly covering every scare that
came by red dye number six uh asbestos
from hair dryers tylenol
tylenol wyatt 2k it's going to crash all
the planes that's kind of like the new
thing that this g5 they're talking about
one after the other
none of it happened you're gonna get
brain cancer from your cell phone the
killer bees are coming up from mexico
and they're gonna they're gonna sting
but what they said about putting metal
in microwaves that was true
well that's true you laughed i made you
laugh oh my gosh that's the joke that's
the one that made you laugh the metal
and microwave jokes oh my god tough
crowd over here don't put metal in the
microwave that's true but we fall for it
again and again it's it's fear porn fear
porn i like that that's a huge that's a
huge hashtag yeah fear porn i like that
so it's no longer what's that
cornhub is going to be fear hub right
for all my twitter followers pbd is
getting to be really active on twitter
so all my twitter followers you better
be following him
wow thanks so so by the way this is how
i see it i see it from the element of
should should some people be
micromanaged
yes mentally ill helpless people who
else who else who else should be micro
man i got four kids two should be
michael okay good enough who could fall
into a swimming pool and die i totally
agree how level of
micro management should we treat
toddlers at what is that a hundred the
highest level i agree i agree right and
i mean
girls boys to should be micromanaged
more than girls once they're mobile oh
my gosh tell me why about the one pack
that why boys need to be micromanaged
more than girls
because boys are stupider and crazier
their frontal
male's frontal lobe develops by the age
of 25. they're they're they're actually
physiologically idiots until 25 some
until 50 some until forever just all
depends don't i know it danielle it's
tough out here
we're gonna we're gonna get you to
procreate one of these days
and when when it happens i want you to
go full speed ahead and make up for the
lost time i'm very happy to know that
i'm i'm practicing every weekend and
then when it's ready for game time i
will let you know thank you very much i
appreciate that here's one example that
when i finally refused to do the scare
stories on 2020 somebody came in with uh
big lighters are exploding in people's
pockets and setting them on fire and
they've killed four people over the past
four years
and it was true
and 2020 did the story they when i
refused they got bob brown to do it but
when i looked at the data you see that
10 times as many are killed by plastic
bags
we don't do stories in plastic bags
because they're too ordinary and 200
americans are killed over that time by
buckets five gallon buckets mostly
because two-year-old toddlers
climb into them and manage to drown
and most of those are boys
where are we going with the micromanager
let me tell you where we're going at
what point
should you micromanage less like what
age should you micromanage kids less i
tell every parent the minute you don't
have to have eyes in the back of your
head and your kids can swim in the ocean
okay you're going to cross a rubicon to
a higher level of freedom okay
will you ever be a hundred percent not
needing to
uh uh watch what your kids are doing at
any age
hopefully if you've raised it correctly
then they have independence well i'm
going with this out of your four kids
five kids three kids
could one need more management than the
others yeah the three boys okay fine so
here's where it goes then the question
becomes the following
should the president or the government
trust
what percentage of people to make the
right choice for themselves and others
meaning
you're not going to commit suicide
you're not going to hurt yourself that's
going to hurt others or you're not going
to hurt other people what percentage of
america should the president and the
government trust
and the rest we micromanage what
percentage
do you understand the question i'm
asking them where are you
there's no lie but no no guys i'm going
to i'm trying to make a point here so
what what do you think is it now you bet
now you've crossed a constitutional line
now you've gone into a different vector
so so tell me what that means because my
question is fairly simple
what percentage of america should we
trust that's going to make the right
decision that's not going to hurt them
their family their peers and the people
around them and which ones should we
micromanage well i think the word
liberty is coming to mind yeah but it's
in a great big document well listen uh
to to me prisons are a form of
micromanaging jails are a form of
micromanaging those people need to be
micromanaged because you killed somebody
you committed murder you stole again
what percentage should we micromanage
and what percentage should we trust it's
a very according to new york
general
none that's the point what do you think
that number needs to be john i'm
actually curious what somebody like you
would say to that what do you think that
is
two percent two percent i don't like you
saying that the president should
micromanage them the president
government local state okay let's stay
there so let's take the president
government state local you know uh
cities all of that so you said two
percent needs to be microsoft okay
okay do you know what the answer to this
question says
the answer to this question
will tell the world where you lean
politically
the answer to this question will tell
you where you live politically i'm
convinced because if somebody says what
ask this question today folks if you're
having lunch with your friends forget
about that you know just ask them i
heard on the podcast today that they
were saying this what do you think that
percentage is you will see if a person
says 50 needs to be watched well you
know where that person leans they won't
be government if a person says one
percent those people trust people to me
it eventually gets to a point where
you ever heard of these kids or these
girls are the boys that are raised in a
family that's hardcore micromanaging
what's the first thing they do when they
go to college like catholic school girls
yeah they blow themselves are you
kidding me like they run a you know so
like it's it's just a whole semester
before they're like i i was drunk the
whole time the hell just happened you
and i actually had to go into the
classroom i think this is a prime
example boris johnson they've been
micromanaging their people and america
right now is trying to micromanage its
people and what biden is telling and the
administration is telling in some of
these states like california new york
what they're telling
their people is we don't trust 99 i'm
liking the new mayor of new york i mean
he's only been there for five minutes
but i'm
i'm liking eric adams saying we're not
closing the city you got married you got
governor you got you got two different
issues let me give you a different
perspective we're all micromanaged
in some capacity meaning you can't just
run red lights you got to stop at stop
signs you typically have to wear a
seatbelt you kind of got to pay your
taxes you can't murder we're all like
there's different levels of you in some
states
okay but that is micro management it's
not just one big free-for-all no it's
not no it's not no no it's not no it's
not here's how this works hey son here's
the guidelines in this house go
versus what you do where are you at what
are you doing what's this why'd you do
this no go over here that's that's what
aren't microsoft those are guidelines
you create yeah and then you hope the
people live by those
guys are
yeah but if you constantly keep creating
new laws over and over and over again
what you're trying to say is i don't
trust the people in a family with a lot
of laws
things break okay
one or two or three fights when you over
regulate kids or over-regulate people
you piss them off and they turn against
you you gave the story of the catholic
school girl i i did the sauce cast
yesterday we had the pretty girl jen on
and she was she had older brothers
and her brother i go oh you had older
brothers uh good luck out there and she
goes yeah they gave me a list of guys
that i couldn't write
from high school here's the list of 10
guys you cannot that she goes i dated
every single one of them i go what
because you don't tell me what to do
i mean that's a form of micromanagement
your older brother is telling you who
you can account for right so adam i
think i think patrick john and i are
going to agree on something as parents
what's the hardest thing to do as a
parent when your kid does something
wrong
do you tell them
if you're a one percenter as opposed to
a micro manager
god i'm sorry i made that choice
it just sucks sorry and you walk away
and the consequences be what they may
and that's how you teach guidelines
right patrick i'm sorry you made that
choice john
i always said
wife would you handle this
[Laughter]
is danny all right in the in the in the
looseness that she governs her household
or is there a lesson
if there's a real consequence
not meaning like hey better luck next
time that's the approach i'm asking you
but this this is a problem now i mean
we're over micromanaging these kids and
now what do we have safe spaces nobody
can get hurt nobody can do it on their
own i mean this was um trophy culture
the the coddling of the american mind i
forget who wrote it but but he he's the
author started a movement called free
range kids where he lets his kids at 10
12 11 or 11 10 12 13. walk to the subway
walk to their friend's house he doesn't
know where they're at 24 7. i mean mine
are getting on airplanes by themselves
and flying
amazing
like uh tom zenner with dash remember
the time the first time we met he came
out of nowhere he's like where were you
at i was surfing okay cool 10 year old
10 years old yeah just running around in
southern manhattan yeah so so okay so
but then you give them independence and
then they're it doesn't matter what the
government tells a kid who becomes
independent when you raise their mind
you're like sucks you made that choice
sorry
and whatever you turn off their phone
you
they don't get to go out for a few days
whatever whatever privilege they lose
they lose you're like sorry you made
that choice and you walk away yeah
otherwise and then then your kid can be
surfing on manhattan beach and they're
gonna be okay because you've taught them
how to be okay yeah as opposed to you
know constraining them to where they
need a damn safety dog and safety space
all that
i'm not gonna use an ugly word but you
know can we look at one more
contradiction
in that you talk about
jailing people and where's the right
level and now you've got places like san
francisco where
they don't arrest anybody for stealing
up to 900 dollars and people are
stealing all the time and even the mayor
now has said we're going to stop this
[ __ ]
we're going to have more aggressive
policing
and i agree they should
on the other hand america locks up more
people than any other country
by far we are four based out of the
population of the world we have twenty
five percent of those that's not but by
the way if you've been to alcatraz they
got a wall with all the stats of the
fact that here's how much money you
spend who is this here's that here's
that and how america leads in
incarceration and that becomes a
training ground to turn a criminal that
was a three and two six because you're
gonna go there and learn how to commit
crime in many different ways and you get
the playbook from the best of the best
right total criminal it's like going to
school to become a bigger criminal
but john you know what you just did
no
i just do you just even strengthened my
argument and i love you for it you're so
amazing because my point is
to try to micromanage more people is not
effective
to to to not my kid yesterday screwed up
i got a call from his principal
so i go in
and and i say yo how you doing hey dad
i'm like uh you know what i'm yeah i
know i know i'm like let's go in the
other room
i said so
what happened just tell me the truth
buddy because you know these guys gonna
tell me what happened i know here's what
i did
you're probably disappointed at me huh i
know you would be i'm like this guy i'm
trying to say no i'm not son you're
you're i love you and i'm like yeah it's
you know i mean you know the decision
it's not easy to do it's not that's not
the right move you just made but you
know that that's not the right thing
says no i know that and i'm really
disappointed in myself
how are you going to fix this right and
it goes into this whole thing but how
are you going to what did he do
nothing
but the principal called because he
talked back and somebody you know he was
talking while they're taking the test
and he was talking to him anyways i mean
obviously to me that's nothing but from
a 1.8 gpa community but for the 4.2 gpa
community that's a big deal apparently
and it's fine we want him to have better
grades
and uh
so i talked to him i'm like okay here
you go you know
if you choose every opportunity to
discipline your kids that's going back
to everything is a crime it's too much i
don't think that's a good idea i think
you made a mistake let's train you let's
teach you better habits let's give you
different opportunities
but you know i don't think our
administration today and many states in
america i don't think they trust their
citizens to make the right choice i
think they want to try to be everyone's
mommy and tell them what to do and what
not to do and eventually people are
going to burn out
and leave yeah and by the way you know
you know what's crazy a lot of people
that are moving to florida they're
democrats
and they're staying democrats
but they're democrats who don't want to
be told what to do their democrats were
like just trust my decision-making
process i've never committed a crime in
my life why do you treat me like i'm a
criminal i mean leave me alone look at
this absolute campaign against joe
manchin i mean how much how many ad
dollars have been spent by the
democratic party attacking this democrat
700 yeah jesus i mean
and
but he's speaking
for for the for the silent majority in
the middle of the country can i make one
point
some of the more three most powerful
words in business or in anything in
marketing are things have changed
someone taught me that
when i was doing cold calling for my
financial firm and i couldn't get
through to people and they said use
these words things have changed it's
like oh what's changed well you know the
comp structure uh the marketing the
capabilities but things have changed
with covid
you know we we're gonna lock down for
two to four weeks to control the curve
we're gonna we're gonna um
we're gonna implement these laws and
mass mandates and all this and but
clearly things have changed and we can't
have the same exact rules that we
operated in you know 6 12 18 months ago
that are moving forward so
when did boris johnson make this speech
in uh two days ago okay yeah so clearly
things have changed the point where he's
like all right we are no longer going to
do the mandates the requirements that
have been done because things have
changed we're starting to live with
covid the living in fear of covet is now
gone people are tired of wearing
freaking masks things have changed so
you gotta adapt adapt you know
adaptation is uh the key to life things
have changed why were they laughing in
parliament
i don't know if they were laughing per
se i think i heard applause
i heard relief no no the first one was
laughing the second one was applause
those are the ones wearing the masks no
the first one was was laughing the
second one was applause i know what he's
talking about at first when he said
we're gonna remove the mask mandate they
were laughing like and he was laughing
behind their mouths yeah so
why it is look here's the other part you
got to realize first of all question
becomes newsome do you trust the
judgment of californians i'm curious do
you
do you trust the judgment of
californians to make the right decision
for themselves or do you trust that you
make better choices for californians
than they do and mr president biden and
kamala harris do you trust the judgment
of the american people or do you think
you're better at making decisions for us
than us that's the real question do you
think we can make the right decision for
ourselves because i think right now
here's the right move and i predict this
is what's going to be happening next 30
60 days
i think 30 60 days you're gonna hear the
same exact thing you're gonna hear
speech from biden and the media is gonna
run with it he's gonna say due to our
policies and what things we did with
covet boosters all this other stuff in
the help of anthony fauci
we are now removing masks and we are now
this this this with kids and we are now
doing this with schools and applause oh
my gosh because midterms is around the
corner do not be surprised if joe biden
gives the same exact same and by the way
i thought that's what's gonna happen
yesterday with this press conference and
it was gonna be a victory and it became
the complete opposite yesterday was an
opportunity for them to do the same
thing you understand what i'm saying
like he could have the same kind of a
situation hey let me tell you what we're
doing due to this we're doing this but
nope they stuck to their guns
and a uk is now making progress and
america is not making progress okay so
and the economy is slowing really fast
so he can say whatever he wants in 30 to
60 days
if this if some of the trends that are
emerging continue it's going to be
irrelevant because his his supporters
are starting to get hit where it hurts
but your key point in that pat was that
they're going to do it because of
midterms that's it not because they
trust the people not because they
believe themselves right they they they
they want a nanny state i mean and this
is the exact debate we're in the elitist
versus the commonwealth with all due
respect both sides do it and and i'm
that part i'm not going to sit there and
make it a democratic thing i think
republicans do democrats do it when they
see all of us on midterms are coming and
some policies are not working they have
to pivot quickly but here's a point what
does a great coach do in the middle of a
game
call an audible you make pivots that's
good you should do that hey the people
don't like your policies pivot so they
sh the right thing they should do
is they should pivot but will they pivot
that's the question we don't know how do
republicans want a nanny statement i
didn't say republicans want a nanny said
both parties no what i said is the fact
that republicans sometimes
see a policy that they introduce that
didn't work and they get backlash then
they pivot okay and then the democrats
say they're only pivoting because
they're scared of losing midterms you're
right so that's a both sides thing not
the nanny state thing the fact that they
pivot on their policies let's go to the
next story let's go to the next story so
we talked about crt which led to all
these other stories let's go through a
light story here that maybe there's i
don't know this could get heated folks
so just brace for impact because this
could get very very emotional once i go
through the story i'm hoping everybody
can handle this in a civil way
but it's not up to me i can't control
people
uh i trust people that's my problem okay
all right so living magazine most of us
prioritize our pets physical and mental
health over our own a new study fund can
we put that link up so we can all see it
new survey reveals that the lengths of
people will go to care for their pets
including acupuncture acupuncture
therapy they're three and five pet
parents think the pandemic has increased
their fury pal separation anxiety a
survey of two thousand cats and dog
owners found that 59 have also gotten or
have considered getting an additional
animal companion for their existing pet
of those who bought
broad or considered to bring in a new
furry friend home roughly three and five
did so to keep their first pet company
58 to teach them how to interact with
other pets or animals or to improve
their socialization skills
when it comes to emotional support seven
and ten say that their pets actually
rely on their own stuffed animals
conducted by one poll on behalf of the
spot pet insurance the survey also found
that it takes an average of five and a
half months for a new pet to start
acting odd the most reported odd
behavior are making loud noises hiding
from avoiding others and jumping do you
agree with this article do you agree
with this article adam how often do you
take your cast to occupy i think this
dog i think this article is singling out
dogs hey
the cat's getting acupuncture i think
this article is singling out dogs i
don't know i i see dog owners they walk
them in strollers they have backpacks
for their dogs they're putting their dog
nancy spends a hundred bucks a month on
dog outfits over here like this is a i
don't rarely see cat owners you have
doing stuff like this i i'm considering
getting one thank you but the reason
that i like cats i've been very open
about this and the reason i have two of
them is so they can hang out and i can
just peace out for the weekend i'll see
you guys in three days you guys take
care of yourself
i'm not gonna micromanage you guys i
trust the science i trust you guys to
take care of yourselves i'll see you in
three days and i'm out and i'll be back
now if you're a dog owner how many dog
owners have to cut short whatever
they're doing i gotta go walk my dog i
gotta go feed my dog i literally bring
my dog to the office yeah exactly yeah
and you literally need to stop but but i
get it yeah
so how many people here bring their dog
nancy brings their dogs david brings
their dogs three times a day
every time kids are way more independent
than dogs
it's true it's true but just out of
curiosity do you have any pets you said
you have you guys have a dog because
your kid is allergic to cats right yes
okay
do you have one or two
one how about yourself danielle uh we
littermate basset hounds
dumb as rocks great great great dogs how
many dogs danielle two two towns two
dogs how about yourself tyler i got two
dogs and they're both
we can't leave the house for five
minutes they will lose their mind
seriously oh yeah okay
you should consider acupuncture yes i
think that's where i'm headed i have two
and you've got what i got two
intimidating sheet suits that's what i
got and then you had one you had a third
dog yeah that lasted how long one month
because he was biting the other yeah and
melva and tico and everybody couldn't
handle us hot sauce eric is hot sauce
that's right
but is this a waste of money
but by the way a part of it like i
remember the way we got jimbo is jimbo
came and jumped on my lap i said i want
to take this dog home i said and i feel
bad to separate the brothers i'll take
the other brother as well i think they
need comp i think dogs need company
right just like here's a question let me
ask this question not to make
comparisons of human beings and dogs
john i hope you don't get offended by
this full disclaimer to everybody out
there
how many of you in here
are uh an only child
john you're the only child
danielle you're not tyler you you're an
only child yeah basically my my siblings
are 12 years older so yeah i'm basically
you're not really you're not an only
child you got older siblings basically
12 years
david uh david are you an only child no
sir how about adam you're not you've got
a sister yeah so so what do you think
about you know nowadays the conversation
like we're just gonna have one kid do
any of you have an opinion of
having only one kid and being an only
child do you have any stories
testimonies any opinions on youtube i
dated an only child once how sweet was
he
a little bit too sweet
he was he was well well taken care of
his entire life and i hope that he
married
i don't know maybe a nurse
yeah somebody very caring
and giving with her time
all of her time what does that mean
danielle unpack that a little bit i
think she made her point buddy you know
he was a little clingy he was a stalker
no no he needed attention like he needed
somebody to mommy him he didn't need a
mom not a not a wife in other
words john how many kids do you have i
have two kids and this is one thing
that's
researchable unlike the
so-called
study from a company that sells pet
insurance i don't believe in that
consumer no conflict consumer
investigative journalist calling them
out right there but we once tried to
look at who does well in life the only
children the
large families and there really was
almost no difference except
firstborns and lastborns did better in
areas you could measure like school
than the kids in the middle
and who knows why
you haven't met my middle the
the firstborns get more attention yeah
oh my god and the last borns get what
more freedom
maybe i don't know they totally get more
freedom the middle kids are just kind of
stuck in the middle clowns that are left
to make jokes
over generalized they fight you did it
john what do you mean you're the you're
writing your study there was a small
difference okay but that's a fair
criticism yeah you keep contradicting
the whole show
the time the youngest comes around
you're just like oh whatever eat it off
the floor i'm sorry you're in the middle
of the highway the time the youngest
comes around if there were four of them
i mean you're just like whatever by the
way who's listening to this and it's an
only child like if you listen to this
and you know as an only child growing up
as an adult did you say i wish i had a
sibling like did you sit there and say i
wish i had a sibling or did you say no i
was good i had friends had cousins had
you know people around me i didn't need
another sibling but are you shocked to
hear his because i think you were
basically inferring that an only child
would lead to
lesser success in life is that where
going this because you're basically
saying that that's not true you look at
kennedy's right you have uh
joseph who was the most ambitious who
died in war as a pilot right but the
father was named his oldest son after
him
and he thought he was going to be the
one that's the president and the kid
that had back problems health issues his
entire life the youngest
who wasn't ambitious who never had
aspirations of being a president he ends
up becoming a president so the dynamics
are very weird when you look at it now
can you he wasn't the youngest who he
wasn't he was the second but he was the
number three i think he was or number
eight because robert was younger i
thought yeah no i think he was the
second youngest but i think
but there's
wasn't he wasn't the designated one no
he would nobody he wasn't getting
even robert they thought robert was more
ambitious than john was can you say how
many presidents we've had that say
a uh only child only child have we had
any only
president's only child it's elon musk's
only child he's not gonna brought her
brother
that's right that's right how many
presidents were only children i'm
actually curious now none no presidents
have ever been the only child george
washington franklin roosevelt
clinton barack obama had half siblings
but no full siblings okay so maybe
that's a form of only child washington
franklin fdr
ford and bill clinton and obama but uh i
don't know i i don't know you know my
opinion would be if it for what it's
worth
i think there's competition and having
more than a kid more than one kid i
think there is things you'll learn i
think you have an ex
rivalry
teaches you how to deal with rivals yeah
i mean jordan became jordan because his
older brother adrian would punk him and
bully him and he says i'm going to get
better than you in basketball i think
there's rashad evans yesterday said he
became a fighter because his older
brother would take him like that so i
mean i i don't know i i'd like to
research his john stossel studied that
he just claimed here that uh you know i
i'd like to show your work john well
this shows your work
it's a famous thomas soul point you want
to see my work you got to watch stossel
tv
i'm a fan go go subscribe to his channel
go ahead buddy tv
this is a thomas solo point that he's
been making for years when you talk
about equity uh of outcome and and it's
all about your circumstances to john's
point a big thing is the first children
usually do better they're smarter
they're more taken care of more
attention is given to them um it's it's
that's why you can't ever have
a quality of outcome in a sense because
it's all about your circumstance i just
i just did a famous only child you know
famous only uh is that the right word i
typed them famous only
you typed in only fans by us
okay ten famous only children is the
proper uh uh english isn't duckduckgo
great that we can just get answers to
questions on our little phone
for free sweet you're saying as opposed
to google
well both of them but i was plugging it
because it's less evil than google but
okay it is we should stop and
thank
guess the
inventor of i should
thank the apple creators because it's
great i waste so much time on my thing
oh you're saying duckduckgo or google
you didn't just that was not a shout out
just to duckduckgo by the way
list of only children lance armstrong
only okay
he's buying himself biking maybe that's
like not another team player frank
sinhatra only child okay the greatest
natalie portman only child robin
williams
wow only child tiger woods
only child
laura bush only child
teller of pen and teller
only child what is this proving this i'm
just we're doing this is
what about musk's point that if
everybody just has one child the world
is kind of screwed
because who's gonna we're keep rudely
living longer and demanding that the
state pay all our health care bills
you're on fire today you start off
disagreeing and you validate we've just
had the birth rating we're gonna have
john move to florida we're gonna have to
have a conversation with john's wife and
figure out what it's gonna take to move
them to florida possibly a taste you say
when the democrats move here
they resent they they stay democrats
they just don't like the nanny state why
not they become libertarians yeah not
all of them or independents but they are
they are you have to realize first time
i sat down with this guy
and i met him and i started talking to
him you know he was in a completely
different place versus where he is today
he says if desantis goes he would
consider voting for desantis even though
he's a die-hard trump fan
just in case you
did your poker side didn't catch that
but uh
yeah so i you know let's go to the story
with elon musk and what he's talking
about i think that's just a perfect
segue into it elon musk lemons the
declining birth rate if you aren't
if there aren't enough people for earth
then there definitely won't be enough
people for mars this is an insider story
elon musk says people should be
concerned about the population collapse
there's people that talk about
depopulation this guy's talking about
overpopulation he wants more kids not
less kids musk shared his worries in a
series of tweets on wednesday following
a general decline in birth rate amid the
pandemic in the u.s the birth rate fell
four percent from 2019 to 2020 marking
the country's lowest number of birds
since 1979 which i thought they would
have more kids because you're spending
more time with your spouse musk is
aiming to put humans in a settlement on
mars he said that spacex will land
humans on the planet with its starship
rocket in five to ten years but if the
demographic crisis doesn't let up there
won't be enough people for mars he said
last month musk the father of six said
that unless people have more children
civilization is going to crumble adam
your thoughts because i know this is
very personal to you oh you well you
said you thought that more they would
people have more kids during the
pandemic because they're home alone
didn't you like everybody was talking
about people
more sexually but i'll tell you this
there's nothing sexy about a pandemic
there's nothing sexy about masks i mean
you're literally had to social distance
yeah so i don't know if uh you you
weren't going to meet up with people at
bars you weren't going to
it wasn't conducive to procreation but
i don't know okay look is elon a
visionary yes is he the richest guy in
the world yes
is he just a complete beast amazing
i don't get the mars thing
i'm just
i don't get the obsession with mars i
would rather him focus on improving
earth the only planet we've ever known
and probably will ever know i've done
some you know how cold it is on on
average in mars you know let me let me
throw some stats your ways mars is
further
from the sun than the earth okay
it's a very cold planet the average
temperature on earth 55 degrees
fahrenheit the average temperature on
mars
minus 80 degrees fahrenheit taking
heaters though he's taking heat okay how
long is it how long do you actually
think it takes assuming people get on
rocket ships to get to mars how long do
you think to get to mars from here i
have no idea seven years seven days
years seven days
i thought it took about a half a year if
you're lucky and it takes a year on
average like
it's gonna take you a rocket people get
upset about doing 16 hours from you know
new york to dubai you think you're gonna
enjoy your one-year flight buddy enjoy
that i i don't get it all right it's
gonna land nobody's gonna be alive
they'll have killed each other by then
100 that people are freaking out on
planes these days because if you don't
wear a mask or fist fighting right now
what's going to happen on a year-long
flight to mars but i think i think
they're supposed to like cryogenically
do something to where they like knock
your ass out for the first six months of
the trip okay well or they'll he'll
invent something like a fax machine
we'll just be
fast over tomorrow teleport you're
talking about teleporting mars okay now
that's like an 80s reference now
teleport john johnson are you going back
to star trek
so temperature
temperature temperature you talk about
six to 12 months what else do you have
there's very little oxygen you can't
really breathe it's basically mostly
carbon dioxide obviously here where
oxygen i mean that's what we breathe
here
and here's another little fact plants
can't even grow on mars so this
obsession with mars sounds amazing and
obviously i've been very vocal that i
think
elon musk is literally trying to bang
aliens that's hence why he made his
girlfriend dress up as an alien and get
alien tattoos and then he broke up with
him people have different fetishes i
don't know he's that's his fetish but he
broke up with her so he's a single dad
of six kids six kids yeah um
yes they are no longer together grimes
uh she was like nine years old anywhere
right she was younger than nine years
younger or nine years old john she was
nine nine years old
30 years ago okay she was much younger
but
the point is i wish that he would use
his amazing knowledge and double down on
green energy and neural link and
everything that he's doing here
and just we're not moving to mars
you know do you think he hasn't thought
of this like do you think he's gonna
watch his podcast and be like you know
what i'm not gonna go to mars i don't
think just made a great point
i hadn't realized that it's that long
maybe he's the wealthiest man in the
world and he wants to keep his share
price up
i just i think it's a distraction the
mars thing i think he's just trying to
make sure that he maintains his mystique
exactly that's why i stopped for this
wait wait wait let me let me ask you
guys a question let me ask you guys do
you think this morris thing is just a
troll like he's bullshitting no
patrick
yes you think he's trying to elevate his
stock price you guys are so funny i'll
be dancing you are so funny you think
this guy's joking you think this guy's
joking i actually don't think he's
joking but yeah i don't think he's
joking do you think people will be
living in mars by the time elon musk
dies let's say he lives to age 100. i
don't i don't hold anything away from
that guy that guy so that's it you're
believing that we're going to mine
dude i'm sorry sorry i'm sorry i had a
little extra coffee today what i'm
saying
what i'm saying to you is i think that
guy is determined to do that what seems
very interesting to me this was a story
about not enough kids being born and you
were concerned about mars okay that's a
completely different thing but that's
the highlight because there aren't
enough people on earth are we guessing
adam you can do so much more though
yourself
you just got to put your mind to it i
would say
i have i would say this actually more
than your mind i think elon musk is
extremely aspirational
i think elon musk i fully believe that
what i'm about to tell you i think he
believes
he would come out with a better
foundation than what america was founded
on i fully believe that like i think he
looks at the constitution says i agree
with 92 percent here's 8 of what i would
have changed look at what's going on in
america today and i think he'd love to
run a country i think he'd love to run
a community of millions of people like
he'd love to be a president he can't do
that in the u.s
and he would love to go to a different
place to do it and prove that his case
study works that look at the kind of a
environment i created i think his
ambition he's that confident in his
philosophies i think that's the angle
and he's going to do that in mars i
don't know if he's going to do that all
i'm saying to you is in his mind if i'm
speculating he's got the money buy a
country if he wants i mean he really
wants to put his mind ready you can buy
an island
i didn't say an island no i'm talking
about a big old country john what are
you doing
i think he was joking when he talked
about mars but the math is just the math
yeah there
aren't going to be enough young people
to pay into the fund that pays medicare
and social security
and it's getting worse the less we
procreate
so your encouragement to the youngest to
go procreate more
well my daughter is procreating um
how many does she have it's it's a tough
one she has just had one and she's gonna
have another but she has the assets to
make it possible and people have
individually better lives when they're
struggling if they don't have a whole
bunch of kids
people used to have a whole bunch of
kids because half of them died
and the others were working on the farm
we're needed for that
now it used to be ninety percent worked
on the farm now it's two percent
that's why we have summer break i
believe and yet when you see what's
happening in the fields you know in a
post cares act world a lot of the
smallest businesses in america why are
they still open
because they were family owned and
family run
you know this there but there is a there
is this whole thing about do i really
want to have kids okay
uh i talk to a lot of people who flat
out say i don't know if i want to have
kids i don't know if i should have kids
i don't know if i want that
responsibility i don't know if i want to
raise my kids in today's society i'm
concerned on what it is to raise a kid
in today's society
you know there are really a lot of
people that are coming from a place of i
don't want the responsibility and i
don't want to be able to raise kids in
today's society plus the crime the
climate crisis is going to the world
will be unlivable 12 years from now the
world's going to end based on aoc what
you said so it's a factual statement she
made that if we go out to space i don't
know she's still here sorry yeah she's
still got 15 million followers on
twitter and you know her message is
spreading she could have like left with
de blasio i mean we could that would be
like a buy one get one free no matter
how much people say about her she keeps
getting bigger and bigger and her
audience keeps climbing in that youth
she speaks well and she's good looking
she is articulate and she is pretty and
i'll give you all that but but all of
the legislation that's up on the hill
seems to be failing okay so to you is
this really a concern to you with what
elon musk is talking about meaning so do
you think this is so serious where there
should be a campaign to inspire folks to
have more kids or do you think this is a
do you think this is a financial reason
why people are not having more kids do
you think this is a
responsibility i don't want to have more
kids what do you think this is
well there already is a campaign
just look at china china had a one-child
policy for how many decades and now
they're encouraging there's nothing more
than i think you're allowed to have up
to three kids in china and the alapta
their biggest exactly so china has 1.3
billion people and they've been limiting
the supply of kids supply and demand
economics and there's basically their
what how what's the average age of
people in china
india is way younger than them so now
they're basically procreate appropriate
procreate and they can't get the people
to do it because they're like i want to
make sure that i've got the financial
wherewithal and i only think that i have
that for one child and a lot of
americans who are of a younger age and
see housing prices as being off the
rails and the ability to i mean
if you've got the if you've got the
means if you've got the wherewithal fine
but a lot of people are like you know
what i can only really afford to bring
up one kid yeah i mean i can't move too
is there anything wrong with that is
there anything wrong with that with that
thinking with that thinking no okay
perfectly logical i'm with that as well
because i don't think you ought to have
more kids if you can't afford to have
more course not but i also think if you
have the money and the resources i think
you ought to consider having two three
four five six seven eight kids okay
think about that yeah okay 10 12 14 i
also think there is going to be a
millennial baby boom because you know
millennials are are
are waiting longer to have kids you a
generation ago you would have kids at
age 21 22 25. all right okay we're going
to we're going to we're going to have to
go now millennials will wait till 30 35
yeah but that by definition that means
that you can't have as many
so okay let's let's go ahead and still
have two three i mean it doesn't have to
be limited by one but the economy has to
be able to lift everybody up right now
and the way that we've been forming
economic
policy in this country you're going
backwards you're basically saying it's
the economy stupid it is the economy
stupid there we go danielle and i agree
okay i'm gonna give a shout out to a
couple people but xena mosiah chevrolet
said reason tv is the bomb john says it
like it is i agree we should focus our
efforts to fix earth but we do need
everyone doing that i think but do we
need everyone doing that i think not
next one another super chat john i
wanted to pay my dues thanks to you i
have found my love for austrian
economics i'm now operating my own
blockchain startup thanks to you and
after today's podcast i plan on having
seven kids the last part
the last part was me the last part was
me he didn't say that i'm just joking
i'm giving you a hard time by the way
rodolfo ramirez said something very
interesting he said if you can teach crt
in school you should also be able to
teach religion in school okay that's an
interesting perspective if you want to
let crt in why don't we let religion in
and bible in school if we're going to go
that route anyways okay let's go to the
next topic here with president biden on
what happened with the press conference
did you watch the press conference did
you no and wasn't it two days ago two
days ago yes daniel were you able to
watch it i watched some of it
i did watch some of it the highlights
yes okay well then let me read a little
bit of it and then you you guys tell me
if you caught any of it oh i've i've got
a really special part of it that i want
tyler to pull i'm perfect so biden's
press conference was an utter disaster
says new york post if president minus
press conference once it was supposed to
inspire confidence it failed horribly
even though he spent most of it clearly
calling on reporters from a list of safe
questionnaire provided by his staff he
stumbled and bumbled and all too often
made no sense at all plus he repeated
his bizarre whisper shout gimmick to
emphasize certain points
when what it actually emphasized is his
age his answers on ukraine were
particularly confused the issue is
pretty straightforward vladimir putin
putin is in a threatened invasion and
will do it if he thinks he can get away
with it at the least he'll try to get
the west to bribe him by promising him
much of what he wants without any
fighting
then two he ought to say putin would win
albeit at a heavy price the cost of
going into ukraine is a terms of
physical loss of life for the russians
they'll be able to prevail over time but
it's going to be heavy anyways there's a
bunch of different things that was
discussed his own state department
during the press conference was sending
out clarifications to what he was saying
because he was contradicting
the state department's plans that were
public
and
his own state department was like oh
sorry he just made a boo-boo yeah they
asked us so you know he just said that
uh he believes there's going to be
meddling in the midterms for elections
and zac is like well no that's not what
he said what he was trying to say no no
his words yeah he said there's gonna be
meddling in 2022 midterm elections
that's not what he meant and then uh
kamala harris was pushed on it as well
she got really upset and even morning
joe your guy came out and said uh putin
and ji see this and they see biden as
weak they don't seem as a strong uh
leader of a country but what was your
biggest takeaway watching the uh the
press uh conference um
look if this article was written by
the washington post or um something on
cnn i think it would have a lot more
credence and i understand that that the
um i hate bloomberg was reporting the
same kinds of i mean even the liberal
media has gotten pushed to the point
where they're like they've got to
recognize some of these gaffes yeah
there's no doubt that the guy is sort of
a stumbling bumbling you know gaff
machine but then again so was donald
trump and that's why biden was elected
just biden was elected not because he
was going to be some super human
uh hero to transform america it was
because he was not donald trump what
what's a whisper shout when he's like
hey listen john stossel
you come at me buddy i'm gonna challenge
you to a push-up contest buddy that's a
whisper yeah and i'm i'm yelling on the
inside
stossel and you were playing volleyball
buddy
um
that's a the whisper shot
thank you okay
i also think that
the media
biden doesn't do much to
um
get a lot of media attention like trump
did so the one thing that they will get
the media attention is look at him he's
an old stumbling bumbling fool oh okay
cool they'll get some clicks i mean you
worked in media forever but pat i
actually want to get your thoughts on
this one comment that he made because he
was talking about basically he's touting
his infrastructure and basically no
surprise medical bills and he basically
said the words we're not going back to
lockdowns we're not going back to school
closings um he said these words
hey look man i'm a capitalist but
sometimes
but capitalism without competition is
not capitalism it's exploitation
so
the fact that
joe biden came out and basically called
himself a capitalist stop i think that's
oh so what stop why am i stopping no no
no like what i mean is stop you know you
because you know i can i can be 400
pounds and tell you cheesecake's not
good for you
you know you should stop eating
cheesecake
what provoked him to say that what was
the question
that was part of his speech i didn't see
him answering any questions he's being
attacked by first of all by the middle
of his party for trying to promote
socialism yeah yeah look the fact that
he even
came out and said that you gotta applaud
him for saying look i'm a capitalist but
even capitalism has some issues well
then why don't you try and back some
capitalist policies hey
i agree first of all listen let me
simplify something for you okay the
other day we showed the steve harvey
deal right with a steve harvey show
steve harvey showed uh
that uh the difference between the
reason why dave chappelle can get away
with anything is because he's got what
subscription description he says not
sponsors when you're sponsors you can't
say everything right okay
is is biden a subscription model or a
sponsorship model sponsorship okay then
he's not gonna say what he's saying
behind closed doors he's gonna say
pfizer don't worry about it but i just
have to say that so i can
get the people's confidence but we got
you i still need your 48 million dollars
on my campaign don't worry about it so
subscription model on who became a
president or who had a shot at becoming
a president is the following names just
so you know not sponsorship whether you
like this or not sanders was a
subscription model
obama's first term was a subscription
model trump's first term was a
subscription model so don't give me this
[ __ ] about aoc yeah aoc is a
subscription model this ain't about left
or right this is why i respect sanders
because he's a subscription model okay
that's a very good this guy is not a
subscription model this guy is a
sponsorship model that has to say
whatever the money people tell them
behind closed doors and that's most of
the presidents we've had in the last few
days most politicians to be honest yeah
but this is why people liked obama and
they wanted trump and they wanted
sanders that's a subscription it
couldn't be bought
this guy's this is not about policies
this is just telling you five ten twenty
forty dollar eighty-eight percent of our
donors are five dollar donor 88 you know
those statistics that they say these
guys cannot say that you remember that
one time who was a person that was being
interviewed uh oh you know what it was
it was tucker had jim jordan on
and i don't know was jim jordan who was
actually i do think it was jim jordan
when tucker said hey can you all this
stuff that you say about google and all
this other guys can you explain to us
why you took a majority or contribution
that's coming from silicon valley
i don't know if you remember that or not
it was jim jordan i thought it was jim
jo i'd like to verify this i don't want
to put his name out there and
defame his character if you can verify
that but the point is the moment you go
that route okay and you take money from
silicon valley you can't sit there and
say this censorship [ __ ] that
they're doing yes facebook i'll take
your hundred thousand dollars but this
sucks stop it stop it you're acting on
what you're doing yeah i said it right
it was is it who is that is it jim
jordan i was right how long ago was that
by the way can you pull that up and say
i was a year ago yeah a year ago i
remember that so that to me the moment
that and i'm a jim jordan guy i'm like
wait a minute
you're taking money from these guys your
bashing censorship so that's what i mean
by stop it you know
i may be wrong no i think it's a valid
point i like the analogy that you did
with the subscription versus um
sponsorship these are a lot of
sponsorship presidents we got here
please john
i disagree that they're doing it for the
money i think the main motivator is
what will people like what will make me
popular
what will not piss people off
the money is secondary
uh okay i disagree here's why
you do that on camera you're right
you're absolutely right on camera for
sure one million percent you're right
but camera is hollywood behind closed
door sitting down doing deals that's
real life all right but we were talking
about this in the context of the news
conference sure i get that but he was
explaining it from a standpoint of
saying what do you think about the fact
that he said this i'm a capitalist
but at the same time you know sometimes
capitalists without competition is
exploitation you're right so every time
you raise minimum wage who in the behind
closed doors goes like this amazon says
do it again
walmart says do it again we don't pay
anybody 15 bucks an hour this people
just want to trash us do it again but
the small guy that's sitting there
running a restaurant says
do you have no clue how the hell am i
supposed to pay this waitress from 7 25
to 15 bucks an hour and tips and
restaurant my burgers are gonna go from
eight dollars to nineteen dollars i
can't afford to do that yeah big
businesses love it when they raise
minimum wage so yeah that's what i mean
by exploitation these are the guys
politicians are the guys with their
policies that eliminate competition
if you leave people alone competition
will typically take care of itself minus
the monopoly side which is kind of
happening i think we would have
discovered this by now that people would
understand look at hong kong
they went from third world to first
world
because
the government left them alone and
people were free to compete
flat tax
and the british rulers sat around and
drank tea
left people
to pursue their own affairs and that
took them from poor to our level of
prosperity our level of prosperity today
or back then
oh i'm talking 10 you know now china's
wrecking it but it
sorry my my former employer is about to
pull the plug on this thing so the
federal reserve
both to pull the plug on
on liquidity on
on what makes markets go hmm
and stay happy
what do you mean by that they're they're
january the 1st they they increased the
the
reduction of purchases into the market
they doubled it so now they're
45 billion less that they're that
they're they're reversing the
quantitative easing exactly and they'll
be finished by mid-march and it's fully
anticipated
so much political
biden at his press conference said it
it's time for the fed to take care of
inflation
not mine you know it's not not not our
worry that's the fed's purview but your
tone of voice says you like the
quantitative easing this is no help me
no hello
right there no i wrote a book called fed
up why the federal reserve was bad for
america after working there for nine
years no no no no oops
no but it's i mean it's hysterical that
the buy administration is placing all of
the blame on the supply chain disruption
i mean there's there i mean you can't
even make this stuff up by the way like
you know this whole thing with dubai
right let me dubai emirates suspends
flights to several us destinations on 5g
concerns uh this is a reuters story the
move is due to operational concerns
associated with the plan development of
5g mobile network services in the us the
company said that it the destinations
include boston chicago dallas fort worth
houston miami newark orlando san
francisco and seattle we are working
closely with aircraft manufacturers and
their relevant authorities to alleviate
operational concerns and we hope to
resume our u.s services as soon as
possible the carrier said the white
house said earlier on tuesday that it
wants to reach a solution on 5g
development that protects air safety
while minimizing uh disruption to air
travel how much of this really is 5g how
much of it is protecting a different
messaging that's happening behind closed
doors with traveling with vaccination
cards how much of it is you know
where do you think the story lies john
i'm going to go to you first
i don't i can't answer any of those
questions is
it's fear porn again it's y2k the planes
are going to crash but isn't 5g already
in use yeah
and the airlines are crashing
the major u.s airlines have already told
the faa no
they told them no about what
about
shutting down right exactly
meaning what though they're going to
shut down flights
they're not going to they're no the
america the american big american
airlines the faa was like we got to
figure this 5g thing out and
it's you know it's scrambling it's not
safe you'd be in the sky and american
airlines or like
not american airlines itself but big
american airline companies i got you no
i got you played this video because you
know
tyler's got this video that he wants to
show with 5g again folks this is just a
video i don't want you to lose your mind
it's just a video title found go ahead
so and then the caption here is the faa
published 1400 plus notices to airmen
about 5g and international airlines they
were canceling flights they warned
pilots not to use their radioaltimeter
at more than 80 airports in the us it
just drives the gauges wild
yeah i mean it scrambles them but you're
assuming the pilot can't fly the plane
and that they won't adjust to this well
he can't fly the plane if he doesn't
have his gauges and he doesn't know
where he's at and his altitude and
whether he's not if he's straight and
level if he's in a bank etc etc etc then
why haven't we seen planes come down
yeah how do i know that's just not a
faulty radar that's just something that
how do i know that's why
you're right david that's why i said you
know this is just a video that tyler
found online that's showing that
uh let me throw some stats your way
because 20 major air um airports have
basically created a buffer zone
all the major airports in uh new york la
miami orlando
uh dfw and dallas
seattle philly i mean there's 20
airports that said you cannot have 5g
within
uh two miles of our airport okay and
i'm not the 5g expert however they're
going to stop it
i don't know but you can't have towers
you'll restrict yeah you're restricted
exactly but basically
where it comes into play is not so much
when they're flying around the sky and
they're you know 10 miles up in the air
it's regarding the landings it's when
they're closer within a thousand feet
of the tower is what they're worried
about and then the airlines of the pilot
unions which are not exactly always
seeing eye to eye they're actually
locked up on this on the same page
they're basically in 100 agreement that
this is basically
um something that they need to be very
weary of because essentially this comes
down to safety yeah over speed i mean
what's the point of 5g it's basically
these
you know cell phone companies are
basically putting up 5g so you can
download your porn even quicker or
communicate even quicker not you john
obviously not you but it's safety or
speed and
you know i think right now we're doing
pretty good with the 4g with the speed
uh the 5g is going to make it 10 times
100 times faster but
look we've got a pretty good
of protecting the airspace in the
immediate vicinity of the airport then
okay
yeah well we've got a very good record
of safety in on our air i don't think
any major u.s airline has crashed in the
last decade even longer u.s airlines
domestically 100
so safety is a major concern i mean
people get scared if there's you know
some turbulence on a plane now if
there's a plane that flies off the
runway god forbid the hudson type things
happens again
you know so it's a it's a safety thing
i'm not the 5g expert but basically when
you see the airlines and the pilot
unions basically on the same page that
should be a telltale sign that they're
very concerned about this and then
there's and then we've found a solution
what's the solution
the buffer zone yeah okay
i mean i i've had 5g on my phone all
over the country for the past few months
i i looked down and i'm like i'm i'm on
5g right now okay do you have strong
feelings about this 5g pet but i doubt i
bet when i'm close to the airport this
afternoon when i'm headed back to dfw
that the 5g disappears
i i don't know you go to these doctors
and they say do you have a lot of
headaches i do do you wear the your app
apple uh or what do you call it earbuds
like i do well we're getting a lot of
people that are coming here saying they
get a lot of headaches from wearing that
you may want to stop wearing that
because of you know whatever radiation
they're talking i'm like okay is there a
hundred percent there i don't know
they've been talking about stuff like
this for a long time they would talk
about if you live near towers cancer
increases i mean
it never
has proven yeah that's that's that's
what you said earlier so
um i think we got to get a good
investigative journalist i think we know
one that can go out there to these
places
it's not going to happen
he plays way too much volleyball it's
problematic so let's let's go i've got
two other story three other stories i'd
like to get to if we can make the time
so u.s senate democrats fail and bid to
pass
voting rights bill okay another reuters
story adam i just want to make sure
you're happy with that it's a reuters
story president joe biden and
congressional democrats suffered twin
legislative defeats late on wednesday in
their push to toughen voting rights
protections in the run-up to this
november's midterm elections that will
determine control of congress in 2023
and back-to-back votes late on wednesday
senate republicans first block democrats
moved to advance
the voting rights legislation toward
passage it was the fifth time in less
than a year that they did so they
employed the decades-old filibuster rule
to stop the legislation which requires a
cooper uh cooperation of at least 60 to
senate 100 members to keep bills alive
the senate currently is 50 50 split
enlightened enlightening speed senate
majority leader chuck schumer democrat
then moved to revamp the filibuster rule
by lowering the 60 vote to 50 by this
time it was not republicans but
schumer's own democrats conservatives
joe manchin and christian cinema who put
the final nail in the coffin by voting
against the rule change they finally
tally on limiting debate on the election
reform before now 51.52 to 48 vote blah
blah blah okay so
do you care even about this story no
okay so this story
what the the question i have is what are
democrats trying to accomplish with this
they're just trying to get get a talking
point out there this is nonsense to make
people think republicans are shutting
voting down which they really are they
aren't so
this is a non-story
but speaking of shutting things down can
we talk about
facebook shutting me down and my suing
them facebook shut you down
i
i did a piece on is
global warming really a horrible crisis
got 24 million views on facebook
and now they won't show it to anybody
because they hire these fact checkers
from the pointer institute this leftist
group
which is i think run by the saint
petersburg
paper here in florida
and
they justify it
by saying well our fact checkers found
your story incomplete
well it's
a five minute tv piece of course it's
incomplete
and the fact checkers say it's wrong
because stossel said this they put
what they say i said in quotes
and it's not what i said they took a
quote from someone else or made it up
and when we point this out
they don't change it they're lying about
me
and so far in the court case that one
headline that you just put up
uh
they said well our fact checkers
are really just opinions so you can't
sue us
but they call them fact checks
former fox business uh host john stossel
soon facebook alleging that the social
media company one that's control
contract the fact checking organization
defaming him when it flagged
two of his videos alerting viewers to
missing contacts and partly false claims
the lawsuit also claims that stasso's
professional reputation has been
significantly and irreparably damaged by
the false labels and statements since
estacio lefox business he's been
releasing videos
on various social platforms including
facebook instagram youtube and the
endeavor has apparently been somewhat
lucrative has made around ten thousand
dollars a month from facebook alone my
news model is based on social media our
company is showing you videos
he he said on facebook but when facebook
fact check and label appeared on two
video stats alleges that his ad revenue
from the platform was cut by 45 percent
interesting so uh are is this done with
is it still going is it still
still going these cases take a while and
i don't care about the revenue but we
facebook used to be my main outlet in
reaching millions of people now it's
youtube because once these idiot fact
checkers facebook just gives up
the power to them we don't like this we
think climate change is a bigger crisis
than you implied so you can't say it
are you friends with dennis prager
i
just like what he does we're not
personal friends you guys have never
spoken
years back
no on the reason i ask i'm not trying to
find a conspiracy here between the two
of you i'm just saying like
he he sued youtube and they had a
issue that they went back and forth i
don't know if he's talking to him his
wife yeah but it was
a lot of good information came out of
him losing the rest of us learned a lot
from it i don't know if uh may not be a
bad idea for the two of you guys to
speak so their argument really was that
you
didn't necessarily
uh you know uh misrepresent just it was
a quote and the whole story wasn't given
so because of that we got to take this
24 million view video down
uh
they
basically three well it's something 40
million
number by the way on facebook
facebook of course 24 million down to
zero who's the facebook guy that you
interviewed
the facebook fast checker yeah yeah he
was a fact he was not a fact checker he
was not a fact checker moderator
moderator
yeah he looked at things that they would
take down and things that they wouldn't
take down and that revealed a lot he was
a guy that worked for facebook
telling us some of the systems and
uh the guy got emotional in the
interview because i couldn't stop i
couldn't work at facebook anymore
because of what was going on but he
wasn't working for facebook he was a
third dependent third party organization
that moderated so a lot of these guys
are third party people that are not
necessarily facebook
almost all of them moderators are kind
words for censors
and it's a tough job because you want to
keep child molestation off and direct
threats of violence and so these poor
guys have to
view all this creepy stuff all day
as the supreme court said you know
pornography when you see it that's what
the supreme court said we're talking
about the difference between censorship
well
again you know it when you see it and i
believe in the supreme court's ruling
but censorship is a whole different
matter well john we we've we've
obviously seen a lot of censorship and
things being taken down regarding and
they have everything everywhere
regarding vaccines we've seen that right
but they can do it legally but they
can't lie about me well they have every
right to do what to take down anything
they want it's their discretion yeah
their company yeah that's my they
they've made it they've made it very
clear that if they don't like what
you're saying about vaccines you're cut
this is the first i've heard about um
global warming though and you think
that's like you're suing them but at the
same time you actually agree or that
they can take it down right but they
can't lie about me they they took it
down and they say i said this i didn't
say this we contacted the reviewers for
the sensors he's he's he's faced what is
it defamation of character position his
position is not a
you can't take the video down
that's the argument that he's making
okay
that's hurting his reputation as
somebody that's been doing this for
decades
and because i'm a former
real reporter when the stuff came out we
called them and said would you talk to
me and two of them agreed to interviews
we showed them the piece and they said
well if you thought we
criticized this because we saw it
no we never watched it
you know what the hell if they make a
public amount that they say anything did
they give you an email did they give you
words did they
write about it somewhere
where we chose to take this down was
there anything that they came back with
to protect your reputation
i'm confused by the who the they is
facebook
no facebook just doesn't respond they
say we leave it to the fact checker
appeal to them and
passing the book
and letting
the people be their own judge
letting the fact checkers just decide if
they're right or wrong and of course
they say we're right
this piece
doesn't make people
understand
the climate crisis well listen since you
you're you don't like to be
controversial i want to read one of your
non-controversial stories here
john stossel is it time to abolish the
fda
unethical to deny americans of
life-saving drugs this is a real clear
politics story thousands of people are
weak
per week continue to die from cover 19
yet america's fda stops people from
taking drugs that might save lives john
stossel weighs in stossel i'm surprised
that we haven't heard more about new
drugs that may covet less of a threat
one drug reduced the risk of health
death or hospitalization by 89 in trials
the media probably doesn't report on
them much because you and i aren't
permitted to take them the fda
makes everyone wait until the drugs meet
the urgent agencies rigorous standards
but while we wait thousands die abolish
the fda
that's your position
yes they've justified
having the right to
ban drugs from thalidomide from
many many years ago when this bad drug
got on the market and hurt people
and that's happened sometimes
but
when they and by the way this drug now
is available they did speed the process
at least
but when they say this new drug will
save 10 000 lives a year
and it takes 10 years to get it approved
that means they killed 10 000 people
last year and the year before but they
don't count in the media reporting or in
government thinking yeah this has been
going on for generations i mean multiple
generations where people have gone to
europe or other countries where
their equivalent of the fda is much more
expeditious in getting these drugs to
the pipeline so if you again if you have
the means then you go to another country
and you get the drug that you know that
you need that's going to save your life
if you don't have the means in your
america you die
and it's not like if you abolish the fda
everybody's going to take bad drugs and
die
it's
new things will appear consumer right
consumer reports underwriters
laboratories
some people will get suckered and will
die and we'll learn from that and in the
long run more people will live
so you are in the school of thought of
trust 99 of people to make the decisions
for themselves it goes back to that same
thing it's our body and if i'm dying
shouldn't i get to try some new drug
as opposed to waiting for a broken
bureaucracy to to deliver a decade later
current system doesn't trust you to make
the right decision for yourself
right in many areas yeah in many many
areas okay last one here we'll do
china's you threatens catastrophic
catastrophic consequences if china is
confronted
they just seem like the friendliest
people out there um this is american
military news during the speech before
the virtual only davos world economic
forum she said that the world needs to
improve move away from what he called
the whole world mentality she also
appeared to criticize western nations
which have been adopting economic
policies and forming alliances around
countering china for example the u.s has
adopted the uger
forced labor act to bar imports from
china's
xijiang region which are suspected to
being produced through the forced labor
of yogurt population the u.s has also
stated that international efforts like
the clean network which seeks to build
network infrastructure using only
trusted technology companies while
excluding companies like china's huawei
in september us australia and uk also
from the new defense of technology
sharing
agreement aimed at bolstering
australia's military capabilities in the
indo-pacific region
danielle thoughts
look he's
he's got until november and he's going
to do everything he can before the 20th
people's congress to bolster support for
himself not externally but internally
and i think we need to understand the
difference between the two because in
2015 2016 there was a global industrial
recession the manufacturing sector
worldwide got slammed china pumped a ton
of money into the global economy xi
jinping's looking for an unprecedented
third term which he hopes to become a
dictatorship when the 20th people
people's congress convenes in november
now he was born with the the actual date
of the congress is a very closely held
secret it's announced very close to the
date of it opening he was born in the
year of the snake people born in the
year of the snake october is a very
unlucky month and the chinese believe in
their lunar calendar deeply
so i say that sometime around november
or so all this tough talk is going to go
away all he wants to make sure is that
he retains his dictatorship so the more
the more he says about the west and the
west being the bad guys the more popular
he is on the mainland and that's what he
cares about does he stand the chance of
losing
there are enemies within and he has
he there are some people who have
criticized his attack of the
billionaires
and
having gone too far in destroying wealth
in china and there are indeed in his own
party uh those who don't want to see
this this third on this is like fdr yeah
this is an fdr moment for china there's
never been a third term so he's trying
to exert himself within the party
within and by by breaking through
barriers that have never been broken
through in
the the the the communist party john do
you have an opinion on this
i will not bloviate about what i haven't
researched so no okay i like that word
bloviate go ahead what's good i just
want to follow up with danielle you're
saying are there only are they limited
to two terms in china here it is the
united states or is this it is typically
it is typically two terms this is this
is the 20th congress but yes and they
come together every six years but this
will effectively
ensure
the
the the strong leader who he has become
remains in this position and how long
and he's been brutal with his
enemies how long are those terms so
there's six and not four years in united
states so he's been in power you're
saying 12 years
and he's looking for another six it'll
be 18 years and the chinese economy is
at a 30-year low growth rate 30-year low
and that's because of covet or why it's
because the country itself has has
reached its limits in terms of its
capacity to be the marginal consumer of
50 of commodities on the planet it's got
a demographic problem we talked about
that earlier and the growth is simply
slowing so any and all
uh stimulus that's going to be put into
the economy this year is going straight
to the people ray dalio's been talking
his book lately and he's been saying you
know it's common prosperity that's what
they call it this common prosperity push
the campaign it's a great thing for the
people of china well just wait and see
what happens after he succeeds if he
succeeds in november and then all the
the stimulus goes poof
look layman turns over here i don't
think there's any chance that he does
not succeed he's a complete strong man
and look at where china's at right now
you seem to be skeptical of him actually
winning quote-unquote re-election again
he has made there are people underneath
him you have to it is traditional right
now in china for you to name your
successor
that is even if he takes the
unprecedented third term he didn't name
his successor last time around meaning i
plan on being here yeah i don't get used
to me and that's what you know that
critically that's what he and putin have
in common is that they're going to be
around with their countries and with a
common enemy of the united states who's
around longer putin or she
in power who's around longer i don't
know what are their age who's not going
anywhere
it doesn't seem like she is either no
well we'll see come november pat do you
have any feelings on uh whether she
makes it uh this third term or not
i mean the way it's looking like what
he's doing but she's talking about a
system so six two it hasn't happened
i don't know this this guy seems like he
is a true believer in what he believes
in and he is one that imposes himself
i mean his people and people are scared
of
of this guy extremely by the way the
other day you saw how anna's cantor came
out and called that china again on what
they said about juggers and all this
other stuff then
not only was shaman have to say no not
what shaman had to say because
innis was disappointed with what shaman
had to say on the podcast but uh uh yao
ming came out and said i don't know who
this enes cantor freedom person is but
guess what if you want to come to china
we'd love to show you this country stop
it
and show you the yeah there it is he
says but if he wants to see the real
china come on down by the way here's
what i'll say if ennis decides to go to
china i would join them on that trip to
go to you and nsk i would join them i
would say freedom if if because to
validate a point let's go see how great
about here's what i can guarantee yeah
there is a higher likelihood that ns
cantor freedom goes to china then he
goes to turkey
you're so funny you're so funny okay
maybe we'll you know what we'll do
here's an idea because i know this guy
that likes to travel
maybe we'll go check out the volleyball
team in china with john
and we'll do some investigative
journalism together what do you think
about that are you open to it
no no okay i figured it out have you
ever been to china
uh no no hong kong you have to set count
somewhat yeah
yeah it's like a half brother like bill
clinton's well listen people love
today's podcast lots of positive
commentary for john and danielle and
adam i think this was one of your best
podcasts ever i think you you crushed it
i'm being serious with that you crushed
it today uh we're doing it again next
week on uh
let me see what do we have you to tell
them today not thursday tuesday we got
who christina
oh christina uh
uh pusha pusha
press secretary press secretary of
desantis will be here tuesday folks do
not miss it it's going to be an
interesting conversation especially if
you live in florida or if you'd like to
see desantis become the president of
florida that'll be tuesday podcast take
care john daniel thanks for coming out
have a great weekend everybody bye bye
bye bye
you